wegzuschauen heißt mitzumachen machen
wir ausreichend machen wir genug hier in
Deutschland haben wir die versprochenen
Waffen eigentlich alle geschickt große
Zweifel daran heute der Bericht über die
nach wie vor ausstehenden
Waffenlieferung hier aus Deutschland
versprechen die noch nicht ausreichend
eingelöst wurden seitens des
Verteidigungsministeriums seitens der
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht zunehmende Kritik an ihr
deswegen nicht mal das liefert zu haben
was man versprochen hat darüber wollen
wir sprechen mit Florian Hahn dem
verteidigungspolitischen Sprecher der
Union schönen guten Tag Herr Hahn
diese Worte
aus München die Klingen hier nach im
Studio die können wir heute nicht
einfach so abschütteln das war so
eindrucksvoll so nachdrücklich so
emotional und jetzt erfahren wir
gleichzeitig das wir als Deutschland die
Bundesregierung die Versprechen noch
nicht eingelöst hat was fällt Ihnen dazu
ein
ja es ist weiter wirklich
beschämend im Grunde dass wir seit
Beginn dieses Konfliktes und dann auch
sogar auch nach dem Kriegseintritt
Russlands und nach dem Überfall auf die
Ukraine wir weiterhin immer bei uns
auszeichnen durch Zögerlichkeit durch zu
spät sein und im Grunde auch den
Ukrainern das verwehren was sie jetzt
tatsächlich brauchen und das ist wir
müssen sie unterstützen bei ihrer
Verteidigungsfähigkeit es ist ja richtig
dass wir
Waffenlieferungen inzwischen machen aber
es ist alles mit viel zu geringem viel
zu geringer Geschwindigkeit das werden
Listen nicht bearbeitet es gibt eine
große Diskrepanz zwischen dem was
beispielsweise die Außenministerin
baerbock die sehr aktiv ist das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen aber was sie
verkündet im Deutschen Bundestag und was
tatsächlich dann unterm Strich auch
ankommt und hier gibt es große Probleme
in der Bundesregierung und diese
Probleme scheinen vor allem im
Bundesverteidigungsministerium zu liegen
denn dort liegen im wahrsten Sinne
Listen rum hier prüft man sich zu Tode
während die Ukraine um ihre Leben
kämpfen aber das ist doch Wahnsinn man
prüft sich zu Tode da liegen Listen und
wir liefern falsche Waffen also Waffen
die man dort im Moment überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen kann und während man das tut
sterben dort die Menschen so kann es
auch nicht weitergehen das kann doch
nicht unser Ernst sein
absolut und wir rühmen uns auch noch
ständig dass wir angeblich der
zweitgrößte Lieferant von Waffen sind
das ist mit nichten nicht so die USA
liefern deutlich mehr das Vereinigte
Königreich beliefert deutlich mehr die
Türkei selbst Estland liefert deutlich
mehr also es ist wirklich ich kann mir
da nur an den Kopf fassen und das
Parlament das ja eine Kontrollfunktion
hat wird hierbei total behindert durch
völlig durch geheimhaltungsregeln die
vorgeschoben werden meine Partei die
Union hat für diese Woche eine
Sondersitzung gefordert am vergangenen
Montag weil wir die Diskrepanz aufklären
wollten zwischen dem was verkündet wird
und was tatsächlich ankommt das hat man
hat die Ampel Koalition abgebügelt und
gesagt nee das wir haben ja nächste
Woche eine Sitzungswoche da kann man mal
in Ruhe drüber reden ich will nur sagen
hier in der Ukraine geht es um jede
Stunde und das hat ja Klitschko ganz
klar und deutlich gemacht eindrücklich
und wir können die Dinge einfach mal so
eine Woche verschieben also dafür fehlt
mir jedes Verständnis ich finde das
einen echten Skandal also wie kann man
überhaupt noch schlafen gehen wie kann
man als Ministerin schlafen ruhig abends
ins Bett gehen wenn nicht die Liste
abgearbeitet wurde das kann doch
eigentlich gar nicht sein also man das
ist doch weltfremden wir hören gerade
hier den Vizebürgermeister von mariopol
wir haben hier im Studio Vladimir
Klitschko gehabt wir sehen seit über 30
Tagen seit über einem Monat diese
Zerstörung man kann doch nicht dann
schlafen gehen abends wenn das nicht bis
zum letzten abgearbeitet ist bis nicht
sichergestellt ist dass das geliefert
ist
mir scheint auch so dass die Ministerin
eher einen nine to five-job meint
angetreten zu haben statt jetzt in
dieser Krise tatsächlich mit Nachdruck
dabei ist die Dinge umzusetzen man muss
sich vorstellen dass die Ukraine
inzwischen direkt auf die deutsche
wehrtechnische Industrie zugeht um hier
direkt die Geschäfte abzuschließen und
das ein grüner Minister wir habe
tatsächlich derjenige ist dafür sorgt
dass schnell Genehmigung kommen damit
das dann tatsächlich passieren kann aber
die Dinge die im
Bundesverteidigungsministerium sind die
werden auf Eis gelegt mir völlig
unerklärlich und hier erwarte ich auch
vom Bundeskanzler endlich eine harte
Hand und eine ordnende Hand danke
herzlich für das Gespräch Florian Hahn
nicht verteidigt Sprecher der Union
danke Ihnen
vielen herzlichen Dank und wenn man